a long-awaited government watchdog
report slams former FBI director James
Comey and several agents for their
conduct during the 2016 presidential
election Justice Department's inspector
general calls Comey insubordinate for
how he handled the investigation of
Hillary Clinton's use of a private email
server while she was Secretary of State
but if the IG rather does not challenge
the conclusion that Clinton should not
have been prosecuted the report also
suggests agents may deserve punishment
the pro Clinton or anti-trump bias
during the election Jeff Pegues is at
FBI headquarters in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning the FBI had been
bracing for this report which in the end
found that political bias did not
influence decisions here but it was
unsparingly critical of former FBI
director James Comey and some FBI
employees report does identify errors of
judgment violations of or even disregard
for policy in a rare news conference FBI
director Christopher ray acknowledged
that mistakes were made during the 2016
election but noted no evidence of
political bias tainted the Hillary
Clinton investigation nothing in this
report impugns the integrity of our work
force as a whole but the report does
heavily criticize former director James
Comey for not speaking directly with the
Attorney General about the Clinton email
investigation we cannot find a case that
would support bringing criminal charges
on these facts the report says it was
extraordinary that Comey engaged in
ad-hoc decision-making based on his
personal views and operated as not only
the FBI director but also as the
Attorney General at CBS this morning
Comey said that he faced an impossible
choice after new Clinton emails were
discovered there were no good options
but Inspector General Michael Horowitz
said Comey faced two doors follow or
depart from Department policy and
practice on Twitter Comey responded the
conclusions are reasonable even though I
disagree with some the report also
suggests FBI agent Peter struck who
helped lead both the Clinton and Russia
investigation may have acted improperly
in August 2016 top FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
texted struck asking Trump's not ever
going to become president right right
- which struck replied no no he's not
we'll stop it White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders responded to the
report it reaffirmed their president
suspicions about commis conduct and the
political bias among some of the members
of the FBI and President Trump responded
the report this morning in a tweet
saying about the text between Paige and
struck that quote doesn't get any lower
than that
the report also found ironically that
former FBI director James Comey used a
private Gmail account to conduct
official FBI business that is of course
contrary to FBI policy in a tweet
Hillary Clinton responded to that
jokingly saying quote but my emails
Gail that she doesn't think that's quite
a joke thank you very much Jeff McGee's
reporting from Washington